so when that [ __ ] happened to you back
in the day what was that a couple years
two years ago
initially how did it feel
it felt bad
[Laughter]
i'll be honest not great was it
devastating though uh i think it was
just more surreal than like it took me a
while to be like damn that was
devastating because it was but like
while it was happening i was like this
is crazy because i wasn't i was doing
like i was new i was brand new in comedy
wow you know that must i moved to new
york that year jesus oh my god yeah so
you and also getting that show
you have to jump over a bunch of hoops
uh i didn't i literally did one audition
oh [ __ ] in front of lauren yeah was
was seth there meyers probably not no
colin joe's probably yeah i think the
writers che and then some of the other
producers and stuff
and you got it yep and then how long did
you have it before they took it away not
long
i mean i auditioned like
two weeks before they told me i was
gonna be on the show and then they told
me i was gonna be on the show the next
day they announced it that day is i mean
five hours in
is when i started getting like
oh this isn't going to happen you know
oh it was pretty quick
i mean honestly dude it's like
i want to be completely sincere with it
because i'm not emotional but um it
hurts me
yeah it's it hurts me it's like um
because i even when i got mad back in
the day i know how exciting that is yeah
it was cool yeah and i know how like
magic like you just
it's everything's otherworldly almost
and you're like floating on air
and then
i can't imagine
somebody just you know you're floating
on a cloud and some guy going
patrick right and then you oh and you
follow the like i can't imagine that i'm
sorry that happened no i appreciate it
yeah yeah there was like a few days
where i was like new york's incredible
i was like i was like walking around the
city i was like wow my city
and then like
five hours later like i hate this place
wow yeah did you move back after it no i
stayed you stayed yeah
and then how long did it take you to
kind of like um
start feeling normal again
uh probably
like this year it probably took a year
my god without noticing you know right i
couldn't tell you know how it is yeah
like when you're like depressed or
whatever you don't really know you're
depressed
yeah until you're not and then you're
like oh [ __ ] i was [ __ ] whacked out
so true yeah so true so [ __ ] true
because it's sort of like surviving
day-to-day and you're sort of there's a
slump
but it's not until you feel like the
drastic
opposite of that that you're like oh my
god i was a zombie yeah yeah yeah
my god i can't imagine that it makes you
nicer though it does when you get
[ __ ] canceled like that yeah you're
like very nice to everybody
everybody i met i was like hey it's
really i'm so excited to meet you yeah
yeah yeah if i would have got snl i'm
like shut the [ __ ] up i know don't
[ __ ] wait george do you remember how
we reacted to it at that time
did we pile on or did we offer grace
because i want to be genuine about it i
don't want to be like shane we're fine
with it but like maybe we did we say
some [ __ ] we were well i know what it
was i know that i know that he looked up
something that i said on h3 yeah and
what did i say you basically were just
saying what you had just said now about
it's a comic you didn't know what you
found offensive about it you could
understand why people would be upset
yeah what you were saying yeah it's a
podcast you perform on podcast
yeah i i just you know i just find it to
be sacred
you know yeah comedy be sacred i just
feel like you mean once we start um
canceling jokes
and bits
it's the end of our civilization
as we know it you know and i just
you know and also what he said was
i mean tony hinchcleff literally said
you know what i mean
one more time for the [ __ ]
in a mic throughout a room yeah i saw
that i was like oh [ __ ] dude
is
i knew that was just going to bring more
pressure to me
yeah when his thing happened again
everyone was like
shane gillis and tony inch club oh my
gosh
yeah but i
yeah and look it'd level up though huh
tony got a little wild
that was that was real wild yeah here's
m4
yeah but again that's another thing i've
said this before it's like um
you know i've seen i've said things like
if at the store if a gay comic brought
me up the kind of things that have come
out of my mouth
like one more time for the whatever
whatever i i'll do it in the room but
not here yeah and they give it right
back to you and they give it right back
it's like you know if i say something
derogatory toward you know i mean a
black guy or whatever then he'll yell
back and say something even worse about
me but it's all in love
and fun yeah and the audience is
laughing
and um yeah i mean i just um
maybe it's because i'm also
50 now almost 50 now you know what i
mean and i've i've seen it all i know
what's important what i feel like and
what's not important and it's not yeah
it's not yeah so anyway um did you lose
any asian friends
no i don't have any asians
[Laughter]
no no everybody no one cared yeah the
comments literally no one cared in real
life no one cared it's so strange yeah
yeah i'm sure don't get me wrong i'm
sure there were a lot of people that
that did
that did bother them of course and again
i i also understood why they fired me
it's not like it's not like when i when
i found out i was like what
how dare they i was like yeah yeah makes
sense yeah makes sense here's a video of
me using a slur it makes sense yeah
but so but in many ways though
and
you don't have to answer this if you
want to but
it kind of
did something different for your career
definitely in the sense that um
i feel like when people say your name
it's like
a legit
comedy entity
you know i mean not just you know
something that's going to be here one
day gone the next but somebody that's
like legit like like when i think of
your name i think of andrew schultz
chris de stefano guys
yeah i don't know if you're friends with
those guys mark normand you know i mean
those types of guys you know i mean and
um
that's the vibe
that you've done for yourself i don't
know you know and if you
didn't have the talent and you were just
that's one thing but you legitimately
have the talent i'm being real i know
yeah and you know how i feel about
compliments
you hate it
because i've been i've been seeing him
all week and i give him he has been
watching you it gives me a compliment
but i give him when i see him my gym
company hates it